now the output from texture Packer is
actually going to be a JSON file we will
need to load and parse the data in this
file in order to render all of our
sprites on the screen properly now for
each chart in the Atlas the JSON file
lists a nice set of data that allows us
to understand more about this chart for
our purposes we're really only concerned
with two things the first being the name
of this chart now this was the name of
the original loose asset before it was
packed inside of our Atlas and secondly
is the data here in the frame parameter
now frame has four items that we
actually care about the first two X&Y
represent the top-left corner of the
chart inside of the Atlas the next two
are width and height which represent the
size of this chart in the Atlas itself
now we're going to use all four of these
values to actually draw this chart to
our canvas now we've given you a sample
data file to parse that's actually part
of the grits game what we'd like you to
do is use this data to load the assets
into our sample by filling out the parse
atlas definition function in the sprite
sheet class